icône de la lutte pour les droits des
femmes ministres de la santé à qui l'on
doit la loi veil sur la dépénalisation
de l'avortement ou encore cinquième
femme à entrer au panthéon simone veil
est une des personnalités préférées des
français la médiathèque du canal de
saint quentin en yvelines a décidé de
lui rendre hommage à travers
l'exposition simone veil un destin 1927
2010 est créé à l'origine par le
mémorial de la shoah cette exposition
retrace son parcours depuis sa jeunesse
sa expérience dans les camps à auschwitz
et son parcours de magistrats tf1
politique du xxème siècle que ce qu'on
ne savait pas forcément c'est qu'elle
voulait être avocate que son mari a
refusé pour lui ce n'était pas une
confession convenable pour les femmes à
l'époque elle a quand même souhaité à
travailler a poursuivi une carrière de
magistrat elle a pu le faire un tour de
france des prisons et améliorer
certaines des conditions de vie dans ces
prisons à une exposition retrace
également ma toute l'histoire de
de la guerre de l'occupation et la
déportation des juifs en france et on a
souhaité la présenter cette année
puisque en 2022 en juillet on commémore
les 80 ans des rafles une exposition est
également axée sur la transmission un
rôle culturel d'information et de
sensibilisation que la médiathèque prend
à coeur on a aussi des actions en
direction de scolaires avec des
médiateurs du mémorial de la shoah
qui seront présents et qu'ils acquerront
des classes de cm1 cm2 troisième au
collège et lycée à pour présenter
l'exposition proposé de travailler
autour d'ateliers liée au retour de la
thématique objectif c'est de donner les
clés de compréhension du monde
d'aujourd'hui pour mieux vivre ensemble
et mieux construire ensemble le monde de
demain une exposition tout public
illustré de nombreuses photographies et
citations qui se déroulera jusqu'au 18
juin 2022